bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 29
novembre histoires légendes et comptines
la fête du conte revient à saint quentin
en yvelines
et pour cette dix septième édition une
cinquantaine de rendez vous est proposé
nous ferons le point sur la
programmation des heures de peinture un
travail à base de photographies pour un
livre et une exposition
l'aquarelliste michel du voisin présente
ses toiles à versailles et remonter le
temps s'intéresser à nos ancêtres les
acrobates des 7 doigts de la main
s'interroge sur nos racines dans
réversible en voyage notre invité samedi
dernier c'était la troisième édition du
trap un frau family une soirée de
spectacle et que les anciens et les
actuels de déclic théâtre
retour sur cette soirée avec des images
de nicolas landry ce troisième réunion
de famille pour déclic théâtre sur scène
on s'amuse mais on n'oublie pas la
saveur de l'improvisation c'est une
soirée festive avant tout c'est une
soirée de plaisir avant tout c'est une
soirée de spectacle avant tout mais
après comment on fait un match
d'improvisation il ya nécessairement de
la compétition et les joueurs d'impro i
il aime bien c'est au jeu du qui mieux
mieux quelque part alors il ya des
règles à respecter mais en même temps si
on enlève le match à tout ça si on
enlève le l'ingrédient match en fait on
se retrouve avec quelque chose qui n'a
pas nécessairement de saveurs et fait
disparaître le tas
de fait ni froid
une grande famille qui écrit son
histoire depuis 1993 le temps d'une
soirée anciens et actuels de la troupe
joue ensemble
douze d'entre eux ont répondu présent on
joue à la maison de canton apte à petit
c'est génial et on joue avec des gens
qui sont petits comme quand on était
petits qu'eux et compte jouer et du coup
on se dit baba ça aurait été marrant sig
moi quand j'arrive il était petit
j'avais joué avec des vieux et
maintenant c'est moi le veut je sais
déclic théâtre on est accueilli comme
comme un frère comme un enfant si on est
plus jeune et on est on est chouchouté
on et dorlotés on nous emmène
on nous aide on nous fait faire des
choses qu'on n'aurait jamais fait
sans cette structure un rendez vous
réussi depuis trois ans cette année
encore la merise a fait salle comble
tu as entendu on à reignac la troupe
l'astre heures bonjour tournis bonjour
shopi et moi l'air de grâce jusqu'au 10
décembre saint quentin en yvelines vit
au rythme du compte
un événement qui se résument qui se
déroule dans le réseau des médiathèques
de l'agglomération
armelle au brier bonjour vous êtes l'élu
en charge de la culture nous
l'agglomération de saint quentin vous
venez pour cette 17e édition il y a une
cinquantaine de rendez vous tout est
fait la fête du conte
chez nous c'est une dans les
médiathèques c'est une tradition orale
nous avons d'ailleurs des bd
bibliothécaire qui sont toutes nouvelles
dépouilles qui sont ou scooter et ont
fait cette fête du conte à cette époque
parce que c'est avant les fêtes
familiales et c'était une manière
justement de rejoindre la tradition et
la tradition orale et les changes
donc c'est une vitrine sympathique des
médias et des médiathèques
il y en a dans toutes les îles y en a
dans toutes les médiathèques donc dans
les médiathèques des villes historiques
les sept médiathèques et effectivement
cette année on a mis aussi le programme
de spectacles dans les médiathèques sont
des villes qui viennent de rentrer alors
quand on parle de compte vous avez des
la tradition orale on sent qu'on pense
surtout aux enfants mais pas seulement
en fait ça m'intéresse à la ccq est
ouvert pour tout le monde dira même le
deal soieries qui sont plus réservés
aux adultes donc ça se passe dans toutes
les médiathèques et puis il ya un
certain nombre de points deux points
forts tous les comptes cette année sont
plutôt sur le thème général qu'on a
choisi pour la culture c'est à dire la
perception la vision on a cette année
une invitée particulière qui est 4
caroline au cirque et comédienne qui est
conteuse qui est chanteuse et qui
actrice du mouvement donc il ya un temps
fort le premier le vendredi 1er décembre
donc dans deux jours au prisme dans la
petite salle ses voyages au coeur du
monde des des senteurs et là il faut
faire une réservation auprès de la
bibliothèque 17 mar assistant carlyne
cerf qui est la conteuse associés de
cette nouvelle année elle propose des
contes des spectacles mais aussi des
ateliers
il ya aussi des ateliers sur lequel ben
qui change je ne peux pas vous donner
mais on le programme effectivement dans
ce petit bouclettes qui est accessible
dans toutes les médiathèques et dans
tous les lieux des municipaux et puis
vous pouvez vous connecter sur le site
des médias numériques et où le tout le
programme alors dû à d'autres enfants
vous disais parce que c'est la
perfection les un peu de numérique aussi
puisqu'il ya des couples numérique
oui ça se passe notamment le samedi 12
décembre à la médiathèque de wimereux
qu'est ce qu'un contenu mairie la
médiathèque du canal du canal par un
contenu me dis que c'est un compte
ai je donc en fait c'est décidé les
média et les bibliothécaires aide mais
en fait les enfants utilisent des à
partir de 6 ans les enfants utilisent
des écrans et tous les dons qu'il ya à
la fois raconté l'histoire et des
cheveux et des jours alors des histoires
des jeux il ya aussi des
animations pour les tout petits oui
alors là c'est vraiment raconter
raconter des contes et puis on a aussi
des contes en français et en langue des
signes
quel est alors là ça se passe à la
médiathèque saint-exupéry donc voisins
le bretonneux c'est réservé à tout
public et c'est le 2 décembre un
mousseur disaient les médiathécaires
sont aussi conteuse mercury toute
l'agglomération qui est en fin de compte
c'est un événement clé de la saison
culturelle à 50 ans ni blessé a mené
moment clé de la saison culturelle c'est
surtout un événement clé des
médiathèques et c'est leur manière aussi
que valoriser tous leurs doutes leurs
compétences et en plus de ce qui est
ouvert au public
il y a aussi toutes les manifestations
qui sont réservées aux professionnels
aux professionnels de la petite enfance
aux professionnels d'éducation et il ya
aussi des manifestations et des comptes
en classe donc il ya 36 écoles qui ont
participé six médiathèques 114 classe 38
bibliothèque f
on a parlé des bibliothécaires de
médiatique m il ya aussi les partenaires
on vous avez cité le président est aussi
les itinéraires politiques tous les
acteurs sont concernés oui surtout
essentiellement oui il ya les
signataires politiques mais des
itinéraires politique ça va très bien
avec lui compte ça va voilà tout ce
qu'ils savent compter donc et déjà on a
beaucoup d'acteurs puisque toutes nos
bibliothécaires sont capables de
raconter des contes et d'ailleurs c'est
un temps fort de l'année mais tous les
mercredis et tous les samedis ils
allaient à une heure du conte dans les
médiathèques
merci armes à l'ouvrier alors l'assiette
du conte se déroule dans toutes les
médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines jusqu'au dimanche 10 décembre
de l'onu allait augmenter comment
voit-on comme mon père soit on à la
commanderie des templiers à elancourt on
y répond en mêlant art et science
perception et illusion est à découvrir
jusqu'au 4 mars
regardez
[Musique]
cette exposition elle a été conçue
pensés et réalisés dans le cadre de la
saison culturelle à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines objectif image
la question que nous nous sommes posée
c'est qu'est-ce que voir qu'est-ce que
regarder dans ce monde où nous sommes
entourés d'image on a une partie
perception qui est dans la chapelle et
une partie illusion qui est dans le
bâtiment regardons nous sommes
actuellement
[Musique]
et
qui a tout ce qui concerne la partie
illusion d'optique donc de la chose la
plus simple à la chose la plus
compliquée et ensuite vous avez toute
une partie sur la réalité virtuelle
la réalité augmentée pour la partie
artistique
on est sur la notion de rendre visible
l'invisible n'a une offre qui a été
coproduite par donc la commanderie et
l'artiste 9 doerig berne qui s'appelle
rvb 255 et cette oeuvre là en fait donc
capte notre image et prend le prétexte
de notre image et du coup rend visible à
la fois la lumière sur nous et en même
temps c'est le prétexte pour montrer la
bataille des couleurs entre le rvb donc
on gère 2
[Musique]
dans la partie scientifique on va partir
de qu'est ce que c'est l'oeil
qu'est ce que c'est voir et puis sur la
partie installations artistiques
nous avons décidé de prendre un parti
pris un point de vue d'un co et
d'explorer l'oeil écoute à la fois vous
avez des petites cartel qui vous
explique les choses et à la fois il ya
un côté manipulation est donc un côté
ludique et autant les enfants que les
adultes
ça fonctionne très bien on se laisse
prendre faut se laisser d'ailleurs il
faut se laisser prendre
c'est l'idée
[Musique]
la perception est aussi le sujet des
oeuvres de mme à flot est pas doué
la plasticienne expose actuellement à la
ferme du mousseau d'elancourt son
installation corps tangible composé de
trois tableaux interactifs réagissent
aux mouvements de ses spectateurs une
performance réalisable grâce à un
dispositif technologique et numérique
l'artiste nous en dit un peu plus toute
ma création et tourner autour du corps
donc notre première interface naturelle
par rapport à ce monde comme je
travaille beaucoup et des nouvelles
technologies c'était pour moi
l'interface première est naturel pour
entrer en relation avec les autres
disciplines donc et au par le biais des
technologies en interaction avec l'image
et le son et corps tangibles et n'est en
fait d'un désir de mettre sur scène des
personnes en situation de handicap
mental est autiste pour parler justement
nos corps nos différences aux
singularités donc il a fallu après les
mettre en image et de faire des choix et
et puis ce spectacle s'est déclinée en
installation
[Rires]
[Musique]
il
[Rires]
[Musique]
faire voyager à travers des aquarelles
depuis près de 40 ans michel du voisin
peint des paysages des régions des
monuments il y a dix ans il posait son
chevalet dans le domaine du château de
versailles
camille lambert pour les images il ya
deux morceaux de bravoure payeur pour un
aquarelliste c'est évidemment la galerie
des glaces qui est quand même un petit
challenge est celui qui m'a donné le
plus de fil à retordre on dirait c'est
la cour de marbre
son livre est un carnet de voyage 128
aquarelles que michel du voisin a peint
au sens même du château de versailles
un travail méticuleux des jardins et des
pièces célèbres ou moins connus il ya
certaines salles où on m'a ouvert la
porte a ouvert les volets et après que
j'ai fait mes photos on à refermer les
volets et on est passé à la salle
suivante
ça s'est passé comme ça et même avec
notamment l'hémicycle du congrès ça
c'est par un député que j'ai pu avoir
accès à ces endroits là ancien
illustrateur de publicité michel du
voisin découvre l'aquarelle il ya 40 ans
une révélation
la légèreté ou non jeunes a pu
l'inconvénient des autres matières où il
ya des parties ne convenait pas je n'ai
pas trop le parti de la crise
à lui s'est réellement loin sécher que
c'est pas possible le vent à la gouache
un peu terne et où donc là d'un seul
coup j'ai découvert quelque chose
d'agréable à travailler mais celle du
voisin pan avec réalisme et élégance ses
toiles sont à découvrir sur versailles
jusqu'au 23 décembre
déjà près de 150 représentations à
travers le monde pour leurs créations à
réversible le collectif canadien les 7
doigts de la main pousse ses valises
cette semaine à 50 en mairie et nous a
rejoint en plateau julien signaux l'un
des artistes bonjour bonjour alors avec
réversible vous remontez le temps
exactement c'est parler du passé pour
mieux avancer sur l'avenir donc c'est un
peu un hommage au passé puis à nos
grands parents alors à l'origine gypsy
snider qui signe la mise en scène
étendait son linge dans une maison
familiale exactement mais alors ça c'est
une idée
donc c'est pas la globalité du show mais
c'est pour l'une des scènes du spectacle
qui intervient la fin donc elle a eu une
fois seul dans sa maison de campagne
elle était toute seule elle étendait le
linge et puis sa première fois qu'elle
se retrouver aussi seul avec aucun bruit
et ça lui a donné l'idée d'une scène
finale du spectacle où l'on revient
étendre le linge le viol un jeu de nos
ancêtres sur les cordes à linge a
justement vos ancêtres parce que pour la
création geste najder vous a demandé à
vous et les sept autres artistes que
vous êtes suite sur scène de vous
plonger ou replonger dans votre passé
c'était un exercice facile compliqué
alors
c'est un exercice qui va chercher au
plus profond de soi même donc c'est très
intéressant parce qu'on parle de nous de
nos ancêtres à la vie l'idée que pour
créer nos personnages de partir sur nos
racines
donc on est parti sur nos racines on est
allé chercher des histoires et on
revenait tous les jours avec des
histoires des photos et avec ceux ci ont
créé notre personnage donc sur scène à
des moments on est dans le passé mais à
des moments d dans le présent donc on
sait jamais vraiment si c'est nous ou si
c'est nos gros parents qu'on joue donc
il ya un petit peu cette cette ambiguïté
qui est très intéressante peut-être dans
la création vous qui êtes dans la
compagnie depuis dix ans afférents ne va
pas c'est peut-être la plus personnelle
sur scène où c'est toujours comme ça que
c'est toujours comme ça avec julie
snyder et puis j'ai envie de dire les 7
doigts parce que ils partent toujours de
l'artiste de l'interprète et de ce qu'il
a en lui et à travers ça il va ya voir
l'histoire autour mais elles sont c'est
une compagnie qui qui va chercher au
fond de la personne donc on part
toujours de l'artiste et c'est ça qui
est vraiment intéressant de travailler
avec le seul droit alors dans cette
recherche certains d'entre vous ont
découvert que la grand mère japonaise
avait quitté le japon par amour une
autre en fait la grand-mère faisait déjà
du cirque
et vous qu'est-ce que vous avez accepté
de partager avec le public alors moi
j'ai parlé de mon grand père qui m'a
élevée en fait qu'ils étaient un peu
comme mon père est un
on a parlé de ce sens qu'il a la famille
ses 65 ans de mariage avec sa femme sait
il a vécu la guerre il ya donc moi je
parle de ça et d'une machine times donc
un peu de machine à remonter le temps
dans mon numéro où des dates sont là ils
font des passes à travers sa vie donc
chaque artiste a choisi en fait un aïeul
pour parler de lui sur scène il n'ya pas
de linéarité ça vous disais ça passe du
passé au présent
peut-être même d'un personnage à un
autre exactement c'est vraiment s'est
construit sous forme quand même de
saynètes on n'a pas vraiment d'un point
a à un point b
on a une idée globale du spectacle et
c'est ça qui est beau parce que chaque
personne peut interpréter aussi à sa
manière les petites saynètes et faire
les liens qui veut donc c'est vraiment
intéressant nature alors avant de
continuer je vous propose qu'on regarde
un petit extrait de la bande annonce de
ce spectacle
[Musique]
m
alors cet extrait on a vu c'est du
cirque
avant tout vous êtes tous circassiens
les huit artistes il y a des anneaux du
skate de la planche lorraine de la danse
on voit de tout toutes les disciplines
exactement c'est du cirque nouveau donc
c'est ça il ya entre la danse le théâtre
on parle sur scène on a des moments de
texte il ya vraiment un beau mélange
vous même vous faites du mât chinois de
la roue allemande du jonglage eux c'est
les 7 doigts il faut aussi avoir
plusieurs disciplines à son arc
alors il faut en avoir plusieurs on va
dire que n'en avoir plusieurs c'est un
plus parce qu'ils peuvent se servir de
de plusieurs talents mais c'est pas
spécial est pas obligé d'avoir d'avoir
plusieurs disciplines après il n'y a pas
que les disciplines il ya la présence
scénique
il ya la danse il ya beaucoup de choses
mais on va dire que c'est un avantage de
toucher un peu à tout après après voilà
ce qu'on arrive aussi à le mettre en
scène de façon intelligente qui décèdent
dit souvent points techniques
il y en a tout au long du spectacle
chaque fois vous avez vous les avez
mises au service de l'histoire ce n'est
pas une démonstration technique
exactement leurs fonds réversible à la
base gypsy snider c'est
l'idée principale c'est le mur donc
c'est une façade mobile donc qui sur
scène crée une sorte de barrière mais
aussi des scénographies géométriques et
puis de qui veut dire aussi le moi
intérieur de en extérieur intérieur
parce que les murs il ya une façade
extérieure et intérieure
donc ça peut être d une façade comme on
fait dans la famille les nations tout ça
ou aussi ça peut être une protection est
quelque chose de intime à l'intérieur de
ça et on essaye de tomber ses murs donc
c'est ça tout le cirque on va naviguer à
travers ses murs et cet espace avec
lequel on va jouer en fait et c'est sale
et du coup il ya la prouesse qui
intervient mais on va dire que c'est
plus l'histoire en avant et si à la
prouesse c'est un plus donc forcément il
y en a mais on n'a pas créé les
histoires avec principalement le but de
faire de la route les capacités de
chacun des accents et ça entraîne dans
une confiance absolue j'imagine qu'il ya
un effet de trop vous êtes plus nombreux
en plus sur les 4 garçons et 4 quatre
fissures sur scène donc il ya une
conscience qu'elle était installée
pendant la
la création du spectacle on a fait le
spectacle ça fait on l'a fait en trois
mois on a eu quand même un mois et demi
d'improvisation où tous les jours on
était les uns pour les autres sur scène
avec lequel on peut compter nos
histoires avec lequel on était guidé par
gypsy snider donc la conscience est là
on a vraiment en mesure on peut tomber
dans les bras de quelqu'un on sait qu'il
va être là en plus de ça moi je joue
avec ma femme sur scène
donc il ya quelque chose encore en plus
je veux dire c'est la conscience tu es
obligé de la voir sinon dans ce métier
là tu fais pas ça 1 150 représentations
en un an
c'est un spectacle qui fonctionne très
bien et les 7 doigts de la main on va
faire un petit mot dessus on va conclure
là dessus c'est un collectif qui a été
créée en 2002 et qui vont offrir un
cirque à l'échelle humaine
c'est bien ça c'est vraiment ça veut
dire on ne peut le prouver encore avec
ce spectacle je pense que chaque
personne qui va être dans la salle
d'avoir un petit pincement au coeur
envers sa famille et puis ses ancêtres
et on va toucher les gens avec ça
échappe on va donner on va allumer une
petite lumière sur le passé de chaque
personne voulait faire réfléchir les
adultes et les enfants s'adresse à tout
le monde sa clémence et tout public et
c'est ça qui est qui fait la magie 17,2
merci je viens celio alors réversible
est à découvrir au théâtre national de
saint quentin en yvelines du 30 novembre
au 3 décembre
et dans un mois c'est noël vous êtes
peut-être déjà en train de faire vos
achats alors le théâtre national à une
idée cadeau deux offres pour faire
plaisir une carte cadeau un abonnement
trois spectacles toutes les informations
sont à retrouver sur le site internet
on passe maintenant à notre coup de
coeur cinéma
[Musique]
cette semaine les rendez vous cinéma
segal pinault qui vous les donne écoutez
ce soir au cinéma grenier à sel nous
accueillons un débat avec la biocoop de
saint-quentin plein champ dans la ville
et avec l'association dédale c'est au
tour du round up le glyphosate dont on
entend beaucoup parler ces derniers
temps
marie-monique robin avait déjà tourné un
film lui-même selon monsanto en 2009 et
elle revient cette année avec le round
up face à ses juges
donc c'est ce soir mercredi à 20h45 au
grenier à sel et dans quelques semaines
nous aurons la sortie nationale de star
wars vous pouvez déjà prêts à acheter
vos places en caisse mais nous aurons
aussi le
nous reprenons le fury road le dernier
mad max dans une nouvelle version black
and chrome donc c'est un noir et blanc
très léché il sera présenté le film sera
présenté par xavier golfique dhabi golf
et c'est un monteur truquiste motion
designer qui viendront parler de de
toute l'importance de
du travail des images la différence
qu'il ya entre la version originale
colorisées et la version en noir et
blanc qui était l'intention première de
george miller
ce sera vendredi 15 décembre à 20h45 et
une autre intervention sur le son aura
lieu le 23 janvier dans la cadre de la
semaine du son vous retrouver tout ça
sur notre site internet cinéma grenier à
sel points comme une séance cinéma
spéciale à l'ugc skywest le documentaire
l'intelligence des arbres montre le
travail minutieux des scientifiques
forestier la projection sera suivie d'un
débat avec michel béal le directeur de
la chance territoriale ile de france
ouest de l'ol laisse regarder
ce que nous appelons arbre n'est que la
partie visible au dessus du sol
oh mais la plupart de sa vie se passe au
sous sol une cuillérée de terre peut
contenir plusieurs kilomètres de
mycorhizes qui forment l'internet de la
forêt le réseau fongiques est juste sur
la surface du sol
nous nous sommes rendu compte que tous
les arbres entremêlait leurs racines en
amusement ce réseau souterrain commun à
tous que nous avions découvert les bases
d'un langage végétal élaboré russe
du reggae made in france à maurepas
taïro et sur la scène de l'espace albert
camus ce vendredi il propose des
sonorités ska et rock steady extrait
encore une fois
répondez-moi allume le maire
est ce la voiture
il est
moi
[Musique]
et moi pourquoi noms de l'humour et à
vélizy-villacoublay avec ben l'humoriste
se passer par le jamel comedy club et on
n'demande qu'à en rire est à londres ce
vendredi un spectacle caustique décalé
et 100% écolo regarde le premier
spectacle à faible consommation
énergétique
[Musique]
j'ai vraiment vu un documentaire à la
télévision sur le tilapia
tout le monde sait ce que c'est que la
télévision c'est pas un pression d'eau
de mer pas un poisson d'eau douce c'est
ce qu'on appelle la pression d'eau sale
et ça peut se manger c'était pas très
nourrissant en termes de protéines c'est
l'équivalent d'un verre d'eau à ce frère
il ya un petit peu moins de vitamines
que dans un package faribault mais c'est
vrai que ça al'avantage de n'avoir aucun
goût
donc ça peut être servi aussi bien en
entrée en plat ou un dessert à condition
qu'ils aient l'accompagnement mais on en
mange et du politique lui aussi a fait
on demande qu'à aurait à en rire à m
sila cherche à savoir si l'on peut rire
avec son coeur dans ce nouveau spectacle
il parle d' aventure avec un grand a
regardez moi je dis sont pas 1 5 fois et
battu dix jours de shérif qui marche à
pied y voilà
la tête que je quand je regarde combien
qu'il est drôle en fait il comptait plus
qu'un scolaire t a toujours été rose
j'en étais
mais pas cette fois après un dernier
rendez vous avant de nous quitter en
musique matmata joue à la mairie ce de
trappes le samedi de décembre le
collectif de brest réponses aux maux par
les mots
un concert pour célébrer les 20 ans du
groupe extraits
[Musique]
si loin des
s'ils ont vaincu passion initiale
[Musique]
turquie c'est à
les champs de rue
le cetud culture est maintenant terminé
merci de nous avoir survie à mercredi
prochain
[Musique]